SURVEILLANCE.
STAY WITH US.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BREAKING
NEWS MONOLOGUE.
BRAND NEW TONIGHT AFTER A
MEETING BETWEEN TRUMP, THE FBI
DIRECTOR CHRIS WRAY, ROD
ROSENSTEIN AND OTHER TOP INTEL
OFFICIALS, PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ARE
ASKING THE INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
INVESTIGATE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND THE SPYING
THEY DID ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS ALSO
REVEALING TONIGHT THAT CHIEF OF
STAFF, JOHN KELLY, GENERAL
KELLY, IS SETTING UP A MEETING
FOR CONGRESS SO THEY WILL SEE
THE DOCUMENTS THAT
CONSTITUTIONALLY THEY HAVE BEEN
ASKING FOR AND THE DOJ HAS BEEN
OBSTRUCTING AND STONE WALLING.
I BELIEVE IT WHEN I SEE THE
DOCUMENTS.
THIS IS THE SAME MATERIAL THAT
ROD ROSENSTEIN HAS REFUSED TO
TURN OVER FOR MONTHS.
NOW, HIS NAME, BY THE WAY, YOU
WANT TO KEEP AN EYE ON IT.
I'LL HAVE MORE ON ROSENSTEIN IN
A MINUTE.
WHAT IS UNFOLDING ABOUT THE DEEP
STATE IS SO DRAMATIC AND
SHOCKING AND SO PREDICTABLE
GIVEN EVERYTHING WE'VE BEEN
COVERING OVER 18 MONTHS.
WE'RE NOW SEEING THE CRACKS IN
THE DEEP STATE IN THE DAM.
IT'S ABOUT THE BURST.
ALL OF THIS INFORMATION IS NOW
BEGINNING TO CASCADE OUT.
EVEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES," "THE
WASHINGTON POST" ARE NOW
CONFIRMING JUST IN THE LAST WEEK
EVERYTHING WE HAVE BEEN
UNCOVERING FOR 18 MONTHS.
IT'S THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER
CORRUPTION CANDLE.
THE HOUSE INTEL CHAIR DEVIN
NUNES SAYS THIS IS CROSSING A
VERY SERIOUS RED LINE.
VERY IMPORTANT.
>> IF THEY RAN A SPY RING, AN
INFORMANT RING AND PAYING PEOPLE
IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, IF ANY OF
THAT IS TRUE, IT'S AN ABSOLUTE
RED LINE.
THERE'S NOT AN HONEST PERSON IN
THE COUNTRY THAT THINKS IT'S
OKAY IF SOURCES, INFORMANTS GO
AROUND AND START PASSING OUT
MONEY ALL OVER THE GLOBE TO DO
WHAT?
TO SECRETLY PUT YOURSELF INTO A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN?
THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE.
>> Sean: THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
CHAIRMAN NUNES IS ALSO SAYING
THERE MIGHT BE MORE THAN ONE FBI
INFORMANT.
YOU HAVE TO BE KIDDING ME.
WATCH THIS.
>> NOBODY WAS EVER INTERESTED IN
AN INFORMANT.
WE ASKED FOR SPECIFIC DOCUMENTS
THAT WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED FROM
THE DEPARTMENTS OF JUSTICE.
THEY CONTINUE TO LEAK OUT THINGS
ABOUT THIS INFORMANT AND WE
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ONE
INFORMANT OR MORE INFORMANTS
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH OUT
THERE NOW, IT'S GETTING TOUGH TO
FOLLOW.
ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR IS GIVE US
THE DOCUMENTATION THAT YOU USED
TO START THIS INVESTIGATION.
>> HAND IT OVER.
THESE TYPE OF TACTICS, SPYING ON
AN OPPOSITION PARTY IN AN
ELECTION YEAR, ARE YOU KIDDING
ME?
THIS IS WHAT YOU'D SEE IN THE
FORMER SOVIET UNION.
LOOK AT THIS.
"WALL STREET JOURNAL."
WE CANNOT RECALL A SIMILAR CASE
EVEN IN THE J. EDGAR HOOVER DAYS
WHEN THE FBI DECIDED TO SNOOP ON
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
THE SAME J. EDGAR HOOVER WHO IS
NOTORIOUS FOR HAVING FILES ON
EVERYBODY IN WASHINGTON.
THAT'S HOW SERIOUS THIS IS.
EVEN CLINTON AIDE, MARK PENN,
WORKED FOR THE CLINTONS FOR 20
YEARS IS CALLING OUT THIS
SCANDAL FOR WHAT IT IS.
THIS IS A GAME-CHANGING MOMENT
AND PENN HAS WORKED FOR
HILLARY'S CHIEF STRATEGIST FOR
HER CAMPAIGN IN 2008.
HOW IS NOW CALLING THIS WITCH
HUNT FOR WHAT IT IS AND WRITING
AN OP-ED IN THE HILL, STOPPING
ROBERT MUELLER TO PROTECT US
ALL.
STUNNING HEADLINE.
PENN GOES ON TO EXPLAIN HOW THE
FACTS ARE NOW UNDENIABLE.
MUELLER IS ON A CRUSADE TO GET
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES TO OVERTURN A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
HE USES THE TERM "DEEP STATE
"THAT IT'S REAL THAT THE FBI
RIGGED THE INVESTIGATION.
AND PENN EXPLAINED MORE ON THIS
ON "THE STORY" WITH MARTHA
MacCALLUM EARLIER TONIGHT.
>> I THINK THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S REPORT IS COMING OUT.
I THINK NUNES IS FINDING OUT
LIKE WHAT ARE THE ORIGINS OF THE
INVESTIGATION AND THERE DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE A REAL CONCRETE
INTELLIGENCE ORIGIN FOR THIS
INVESTIGATION.
WITHOUT A FOUNDATION ONE
WONDERING WHAT DID WE SPENT AN
ENTIRE YEAR ON, WHAT DID WE
DISRUPT EVERYONE IN THE
CAMPAIGN, IN THE ADMINISTRATION.
>> Sean: AND TED OLSEN IS OUT
WITH A NEW PIECE WHERE HE I'M
PLACES HERSELF AND HOW ROBERT
MUELLER'S WITCH HUNT CAN BE
SETTING UP A MASSIVE
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
SHERYL ATKINSON CALLED THE
COLLUSION AGAINST TRUMP AND
ENTIRE TIMELINE.
SHE BREAKS DOWN EVERY SINGLE KEY
MOMENT IN THIS ENTIRE MASSIVE
ABUSE OF POWER SCANDAL.
WE WILL REFER TO THIS THROUGHOUT
HISTORY.
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR
18 MONTHS.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA ARE FINALLY
STARTING TO CATCH ON AND ADMIT
THAT WHAT WE'VE BEEN REPORTING
AND WHAT OTHERS ON THE SHOW HAVE
BEEN REPORTING AND OTHER PEOPLE
WHAT WE'VE BEEN COVERING, WE'RE
BEING PROVEN RIGHT.
THEY HAVE TO ADMIT IT.
LOOK AT THIS HEADLINE FROM "THE
WASHINGTON POST."
"SECRET FBI SOURCE FOR RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION MET WITH THREE
TRUMP ADVISERS."
A "USA TODAY" REPORT.
IT SAYS -- BY THE WAY, EVEN
LIBERAL CNN CAN'T IGNORE ALL THE
FACTS, ALL THE EVIDENCE.
OKAY.
IT'S TAKEN THEM OVER A YEAR.
FINALLY THE MEDIA HAS MISSED THE
SINGLE BIGGEST STORY IN THEIR
LIFETIME.
NOW IT'S A MASSIVE ABUSE OF
POWER.
WE FIRST REPORTED ON THIS MARCH
7, 2017 ABOUT FISA SURVEILLANCE
OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE HAS EVERY
SINGLE RIGHT TONIGHT TO BE
OUTRAGED ABOUT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED.
HE HAS EVERY RIGHT TO WANT TO
KNOW THE TRUTH.
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, NEED
TO KNOW THE TRUTH.
WE NEED TO EXPOSE ALL OF THIS
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR, ALL OF THESE
DEEP-STATE ACTORS NEED TO BE
EXPOSED AND ALL OF THEM HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL, ROD
ROSENSTEIN, HE'S QUICK TO
RESPOND TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
DEMANDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT
ALL.
SO ROSENSTEIN HAS MADE HIMSELF
OUT TO BE A HERO BUT IT'S A
TOTAL FARCE.
HERE'S WHY.
ROSENSTEIN IS DOING WHAT HE
ALWAYS DOES, PROTECTING HIS DEEP
STATE FRIENDS.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL, HE
KNOWS THAT BY REFERRING THIS TO
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL, IT WILL
BUY THEM A YEAR TO 18 MONTHS AND
PROTECT ALL OF THESE DEEP STATE
ACTORS.
NOW IT'S GOING TO TAKE MICHAEL
HOROWITZ OVER A YEAR.
WE DON'T HAVE OVER A YEAR TO
UNCOVER THIS.
WE NEED A FULL FBI DOJ RANK AND
FILE FIELD OFFICE INVESTIGATION
INTO ALL OF THIS.
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO IS
SLOWLY LEAK OUT THIS INFORMATION
A SLOW BLEED TO COVER
THEMSELVES.
IT'S ALL ACYA.
REMEMBER, THEY KNOW WHAT IS OUT
THERE.
THEY KNOW THEY'RE ABOUT TO GET
CAUGHT.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT CONTROLLING
THE NARRATIVE, SPINNING THE
NARRATIVE, TRYING TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND THEY PROBABLY
LEARNED A THING OR TWO FROM
HILLARY ABOUT ACID WASHING HARD
DRIVES.
WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL.
ANOTHER MAJOR COMPONENT.
ROSENSTEIN, THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL DOESN'T HAVE ANY
PROSECUTORIAL POWER.
HOROWITZ CAN'T INDICT PEOPLE.
HE CAN ONLY GIVE CRIMINAL
REFERRALS LIKE IN THE CASE OF
ANDREW McCABE.
THE FBI AND THE DOJ GET TO
REVIEW AND TRY TO REFUTE FACTS
AND REDACT INFORMATION, PROBABLY
FALSELY IN THE NAME OF NATIONAL
SECURITY.
WE'VE BEEN SAYING CONGRESS NEEDS
TO SEE THESE DOCUMENTS.
WE HAVE CHECKS AND BALANCES,
SEPARATION OF POWERS, CO-EQUAL
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT.
THEY'RE PURPOSELY OBSTRUCTING.
LOOKS LIKE SOME OF THIS MIGHT
START TO HAPPEN.
SARAH CARTER WILL JOINS US.
ANOTHER BREAKING STORY, SECRET
FISA DOCUMENTS.
ROD ROSENSTEIN SIGNED THE FINAL
WARRANT, USING THE FAKE FISA
DOCUMENT TO SPY ON CARTER PAGE.
USING THE UNVERIFIED, NEVER
CORROBORATED CLINTON BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR, FOREIGN NATIONAL
DOSSIER OF RUSSIAN LIES.
SARAH IS REPORTING IN APRIL THE
FBI REFUSED TO TURN OVER
DOCUMENTS THAT CHAIRMAN NUNES
AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR.
YOU KNOW, PHONY CLAIMS OF
NATIONAL SECURITY RISKS.
AS WE HAVE SEEN, IT'S ONE EXCUSE
TO STONE WALL AFTER ANOTHER.
ALL TO PREVENT CONGRESS FROM
KNOWING THE TRUTH AND FULFILLING
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE.
CHAIRMAN NUNES, HE'S NOW PUTTING
HIS FOOT DOWN.
IN THIS STANDOFF WITH ROSENSTEIN
AND THE DOJ.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAD WHAT I THOUGHT IS A
PRODUCTIVE MEETING.
AFTER THAT MEETING, THEY HAVE
DONE NOTHING BUT LEAK AND LEAK.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO IT IS OVER AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OR
FBI.
I'M NOT PINNING IN I BLAME ON
PEOPLE.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ANOTHER
MEETING WHERE WE DON'T GET
DOCUMENTS AND THE MEETING LEAKS
OUT.
>> Sean: THE CHAIRMAN IS GETTING
CLOSE.
THE ENTIRE TRUTH IS STARTING TO
COME OUT.
THANKFULLY.
BY THE WAY, DESPITE ROSENSTEIN
STONE WALLING.
NOW BECAUSE OF ALL OF THESE NEW
DEVELOPMENTS, YOU HAVE DEEP
STATE ACTORS, FORMER, COMMUNIST
VOTING JOHN BRENNAN.
KNOWN LIAR, JOHN CLAPPER.
SALLY YATES.
THEY'RE ALL LOSING THEIR MINDS
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL ABOUT TO BE
EXPOSED.
BRENNAN SAYING SENATOR
McCONNELL, IF MR. TRUMP
CONTINUES ALONG THIS DISASTROUS
PATH, YOU'LL WILL BEAR MAJOR
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE HARM FOR
OUR DEMOCRACY.
BY THE WAY, WE'RE A REPUBLIC.
YOU DO A DISSERVICE IF YOU
CONTINUE TO ENABLE MR. TRUMP'S
SELF-SERVING ACTIONS.
BRENNAN IS UP TO HIS EYEBALLS IN
ALL OF THIS.
I'M CERTAIN THAT WILL BE
EXPOSED.
AS WE HAVE BEEN SAYING ON THIS
PROGRAM, HE'S BEEN LYING ABOUT
HIS INVOLVEMENT WITH THIS
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
DOSSIER FOR MONTHS AND HE LIED
IN FRONT OF CONGRESS.
AS FOR JAMES CLAPPER, HE'S
ENSNARED IN THE DOSSIER SCANDAL.
AND CLAPPER, JUST LIKE YATES AND
BRENNAN, LET'S GO AFTER THE
PRESIDENT AND ATTACK HIM.
>> IT'S A VERY DISTURBING
ASSAULT ON THE INDEPENDENCE OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT -- THIS
PRESIDENT OR ANY PRESIDENT TRIES
TO USE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AS A PRIVATE INVESTIGATE
AS A PRIVATE INVESTIGAOR
AS A PRIVATE INVESTIGAORY
AS A PRIVATE INVESTIGAORY I
AS A PRIVATE INVESTIGAORY IS
NOT GOOD FOR THE GOVERNMENT.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT THE RUSSIANS
WERE DOING.
WERE THEY ATTEMPTING TO
INFILTRATE THE CONCERN?
THAT WAS THE CONCERN.
IN MY BELIEF THAT'S WHAT THE
FOCUS OF THIS ACTIVITY ABOUT.
>> Sean: THE SAME CLAPPER THAT
BRAGGED ABOUT THE FBI SPYING ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND SAID IT
THIS IS PROBLEMATIC.
AND THEN GOOD OLD SALLY YATES
THAT SIGNED OFF ON ONE OF THE
FISA WARRANTS LIKE ROSENSTEIN
AND WAS E-MAILING WITH
AND WAS E-MAILING WITH AN
AND WAS E-MAILING WITH ANDR
AND WAS E-MAILING WITH ANDREW
WEISSMAN AFTER SHE REFUSED TO
ENFORCE THE TRAVEL BAN.
YATES IS TRASHING THE PRESIDENT.
WHY?
TO SAVE AND PROTECT HERSELF.
WATCH THIS.
>> DONALD TRUMP HIMSELF ACCUSING
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION OF
IMPROPERLY TARGETING HIS
CAMPAIGN FOR AN INVESTIGATION.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE TO
EVERYTHING YOU HEARD OVER THE
WEEKEND?
>> OBVIOUSLY I'M NOT GOING TO
COMMENT ON THE SPECIFIC FACT
THERE'S.
IT'S UP TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO DECIDE WHAT
INFORMATION SHOULD BE MADE
PUBLIC WITH RESPECT TO THAT.
YOU KNOW, I THINK WHAT WE'RE
SEEING HERE IS THE PRESIDENT HAS
JUST TAKEN HIS ALL-OUT ASSAULT
ON THE RULE OF LAW TO A NEW
LEVEL.
THIS TIME HE IS ORDERING UP AN
INVESTIGATION OF THE
INVESTIGATORS WHO ARE EXAMINING
HIS OWN CAMPAIGN.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S REALLY
SHOCKING.
>> Sean: A HARD-HITTING
INTERVIEW BY LIBERAL JOY.
THESE GUYS ARE SCARED OUT OF
THEIR MIND.
THEY'RE DIRECTLY IMPLICATED IN
THIS.
IT'S TIME TO ASK.
WHAT DID THEY KNOW AND WHEN DID
THEY KNOW IT.
LIKE'S BEEN SAYING ABOUT JAMES
COMEY, WHO BY THE WAY, JAMES, I
WARNED YOU, YOU HAD THE RIGHT TO
REMAIN SILENT.
YOU DIDN'T LISTEN.
INSTEAD OF RUNNING THEIR MOUTHS,
THEY MIGHT WANT TO LAWYER UP AND
MANY OF THEM ARE.
YEAH, JAMES COMEY HIRED THREE
LAWYERS.
THE THREE PEOPLE HE LEAKED
DOCUMENTS TOO.
GREAT.
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE FOR
EVERYBODY BUT ME.
BIG DEVELOPMENT TO TELL YOU
ABOUT.
THE SOON-TO-BE RELEASED DOJ I.G.
REPORT ON THE CLINTON E-MAIL
SERVER INVESTIGATION IS EXPECTED
TO SLAM FBI LEADERS JUST LIKE
COMEY, ANDREW McCABE FOR TAKING
WEEKS TO REVEAL UMA E-MAILS.
IF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
HOROWITZ DOES HIS JOB AND HIS